For quantitative traits like height we can't use
concordance because it's not a simple yes no matching
for height. Remember, concordance means there's agreement between
our categories. So we've got brown, blue, green and
we're looking for matching between our twins. But
quantitative traits don't have these categories, so instead what
we're doing is we're measuring over a range of
possibilities. And so we're going to actually make what's called
a correlation rather than a concordance. A correlation
is a statistical term referring to an observable relationship
between any paired values. Well what does that mean
exactly? What it means is that if we have
a pair of twins where, one twin has a
height that's almost the same as the height of
the other twin, we would say that these are
correlated. Twin one and twin two both had roughly
the same height. If across many pairs of twins, the height
of twin one is very similar to the height of twin
two, then this results in what we call a strong correlation.
But if instead you see that the height measurements between twin
one and twin two are very different, then we would say
that there is a weak or no correlation at all. Now
most of the time we don't look at these kinds of
numbers in table format. We look at them in graph form.
Take a look at these four graphs right here
comparing twin height between twin one and twin two. Essentially
what we've done, is we measured the twin height
for twin one, and then we go up and plot
a point where we get to the twin height of twin two. And we do this for a huge
number of twins, and we have four different results. I
want you to rate the graphs from strongest correlation with
the number one to the weakest weakest correlation with
the number four. Put the numbers 1, 2, 3,
and 4 in the text boxes you see here,
ranking each graph in order of strongest to weakest correlation.
Now this could be a little more difficult if
you don't have any experience with statistics or looking
at correlation graphs before, but I still want you
to give it a shot and see how you do.